the thing about a job bro you can have
you in an apartment you can have you a
house your kids your girl your wife
Cardinals and all that type of [__] if
your manager don't like you he can End
online so you gotta act like you like
somebody just so you can keep your life
straight your girl happy your kids fed
and all that type of [__] you know what
I'm saying and I say that because when I
got fired after that I was homeless I
was in Bakersfield at the time and I was
living in my car that's why I said when
you two came from like an options I
don't have nothing else to do I was a
felon I went to jail and I was 23 so
that [__] [__] me up and so me making
YouTube videos on my car that's when
people connected they ain't seen nobody
living in a car making YouTube videos
we're just downfall bro I lost my kids I
lost my apartment I lost everything
[__] after you got fired yeah so my
mama got sick I'm going to Vegas it's
like 2017. and that's when I just went
hard to [__] that's why today bro this
is my first ever interview I've ever did
in my life because I just don't trust
people
thank you